Before we can begin to create or
even recreate visualizations, we need to understand data and data types.
Almost anything can be turned into data.
Let's take a look at a well noted graphic, and see its data types.
This visualization comes from Hans Rothstein's work with global health data.
If you have five minutes, I highly encourage you to watch Hans narrate
this visualization in the video linked in the instructor notes.
Han gives a charismatic performance that makes this data come alive.
Now, I want to highlight the different data types that can be found in
this visualization.
Let's start with the quantitative data, or
any variables that have exact numbers.
These include variables like life expectancy,
income per person, total population, and year.
Quantitative data can be discreet or
continuous, and typically, variables that are countable are considered discreet.
In this case, total population would be considered a discreet variable,
while income per person would be a continuous variable.
Another data type that appears in this visualization is categorical data.
Nominal data is a way of labelling or categorizing the data into groups.
In this case, the countries of the world are grouped into regions.
The Americas are colored yellow, and sub-Saharan Africa is colored blue.
Categorical data may take on numerical values, but
these numerical values won't necessarily carry any mathematical meaning.
One final type of data not shown in this visualization, is ordered data.
Ordered data is similar to categorical data,
except that the categories are ordered or ranked in some particular way.
One example would be is if I took the populations of each country, and
then split them up into bins.
For example, I could have four groups where each of the countries falls into
a population bin if their population is between 0 and 10 million, 10 and
100 million, 100 and 500 million, or greater than 500 million.
In this example, we're pretty much just taking quantitative data, and
splitting it into groups.
So we have bins or categories of other types of data.
A slightly different example would be class difficulty, such as beginner,
intermediate, and advanced.
Those three types of classes would be a way that we could label the classes, and
they have a natural order in increasing difficulty.
As data scientists, it's important for
us to know that each of these data types can be encoded visually.
And in the next few videos, we'll dive into how we can make
appropriate choices for visual encodings, based on the different data types.
This was just a brief overview of data types.
And if these concepts are still a bit fuzzy for you, we recommend that you
watch the three videos from the Instructional Data Science class.
These videos are linked in the instructor notes.